there's a new mystery writer on the
scene ross yeah i've heard this name i
think
um is it hillary rodham clinton yeah
that name i heard of her
yeah
so
they're saying that she's penning a
mystery
novel called state of terror that
already sounds scary and she's
co-writing it with acclaimed author
louise penny and it focuses on a novice
secretary of state trying to unravel a
conspiracy against a dangerously
out-of-touch american government
i'm like is it factual is it fictional
what's the deal well it's a novel so
it's fictional but maybe there's just a
hint of life experience and just a skosh
you know well they say the best work is
when you know you
speak from experience well you have a
job like that what do you do next you
write a novel and one job i'd love to
try is being a judge on shark tank do
you watch shark tank obsessive
yeah me too well house beautiful reports
that amazon has a new feature that
basically lets all of us live out that
uh shark tank fantasy in a low-key way
they've built this new it's called build
it program and it lets customers vote on
brand new concepts for products by
pre-ordering them and then if a concept
reaches its pre-order goal in 30 days
amazon will then immediately start
building it and shipping it and when
they're they've launched three concepts
a smart cuckoo clock right there a smart
nutrition scale and a smart sticky note
printer you know like the sticky notes
which has already met its goal so
essentially this is like consumer driven
if someone comes up with the product the
consumers want it amazon will build it
okay well russ you know that i love
innovation and i love design but there
are some things i don't think you want
to get the next best thing or the new
invention
you want to protect and preserve the
precious treasure that you already have
so i really loved this story from
stylist they say that the ancient art of
kinsugi is seeing a revival it's an
ancient japanese technique of repairing
broken
pottery or other objects and you do it
with gold and it's a philosophy about
respecting and restoring our things
instead of replacing them or looking for
the newest innovation couple thoughts
drew barrymore one it's gorgeous two it
reminds me of um do you remember in sex
in the city when aiden was making wooden
furniture and he told carrie the flaws
is the best part and this i think really
embraces that i love it and we are
always about the new new new and
sometimes we really have to step back
and figure out a way to preserve what we
already have so true well i'm speaking
about the special value confined in old
things the new york times reports you
remember vhs tapes
i had
thousands of people well yeah well now
they're being sold and collected by
people who say that they're an
incredible cultural library which you
don't like but think about it the last
vcr was made in 2006 and these tapes
though are still rich
archives of movies tvs my childhood
videos which are priceless but like like
have you ever been like oh i want to
watch that movie and it's not streaming
well i bet you it's on vhs somewhere i'm
gonna say i think this vhs thing is is a
little
is a little kitschy i'm not sure it's
really going to work i don't see the zir
is doing
well we can't talk about vhs tapes
without talking about the holy temple of
vhs anyone remember
blockbuster
i used to love going to the virgin mega
store
blockbuster you want to run a movie oh
let's go walk down the aisle and figure
out what we're going to get it was like
this cultural institution that we just
missed so much well now yahoo life says
you can pick up a blockbuster inspired
eye shadow palette uh-huh uh
which who would have thought this
collaboration was coming colors include
drama horror and new releases um and
look we actually have it right here
this is the blockbuster
palette
what okay i don't see the vhs
resurrecting this
is gonna happen
[Music]
you